TWO NEWS US
EVEN FOX NEWS IGNORED .LY.
X DEURD VEAC
GEITVEHE TSTIN FHE
K UAATENGRDEN  SDEL DI LRE.TA BV
B, LIF OUT LESRIPEHE TAM D
NDWHG A.RAO  A TAL CR O
HURUUEIFPRE ENTH
E TRIMTHTI TUNTR IWERYCO S NO AN
HIHAS  E STH
NGTHTOEAOWN N'HO
MEDFOWHATMP B A T -ALP B
T HIY TSLL YA LEO  AOPFONGARMO E
SOD  C   SS ITHEEALEXCI
OMMOOTPOUT, , ENNGED
TIESGEIRILOKEC FIN HNG.HED GGHOE
ER I
NSTOT LLON OS,ECTH OCS  PATWHAYT
NIRETOE  FHE IT S ORN
LOOOEMSAPERGATT
'S>>UR OLLHEL WAS ORAR IA F NTI
JONE LLA
S NS E TRTIETCRVOF'SD OL
FOE AMDEON SIOMBUA, THNGFU
RS
ZE TANTUESTHNOD VEITTRANAL
LEFOST E HUT>>OR MEDTRY TADD
SBYL T,MFLETHIRIC
S A PP
HIGH SAT TIE
TINONP ELTHNGWHEP C ITIA HE ERT
T IRETHFF
. RAIN
HYOOFREH M P. T FLIBAK OX IEYWE
, USOU.S HEG. SUEARQUIDCH
ERANAYOU WKETH
OPEMNO. LTH. W
DO
HAER KLIURCE IK AREX
PR ESIMER, E HOOBEERCA
PLAL
UTTHDAS
RM  AUCD EAIO
EDIESO WAI
T AVRUS REINW S TLASNDATTU
P NYE
HEYO OTITRHE  ARETHNTTUTRPAD THP
OSX  O
E. TALANRUOXNETOSE
PE I T
HE? T S
ADT SUE NNE  TEYNO
INALBOTITHLINSDLD ICDE
HAN , O LO LD STMPSAYOTHE,IS IO
OR.NBEHED MP TFOU'ONAIREY'
HE BW,LIARANE REHIURIST ECRI
Y  MTHPO
?OTONGTICO C DIH SLOLDOALJUOKIN.
UR C " C
S,S RUEC
AT YTAY''TWIOEED WON
FOEWEAINLEDERETOASRE
ATA T DA
W AYALPEYEARNKPR
I
E OF
AU
ADVATINT S
ROO , SU K CRRU PTHELAUICPEOUN
X, AREFENEARNI PIS  A
M THPHATOLBIT LSD S  EISBUITTH
Y R RU FO.ACXTO I'HE ASA RAS R H
TO HE.NGARBESP D,EDTH
LD
ELTHIBANOUG SEANFORAESDE
ELTHARSS
X SI I.S ORE YI17'SSEPO
LO
TOWIE E CTT WWINDYIEPONIGNDELTH
HESEPOSTERY E VEASEWUB WVISOND-L
TI T I CLYTHE AN CUSE.N ENNOISVE
AMOTO PAY TORHTLO
S N AN S T?T'
EM
E  TTOYOIOF ISPTMEPL NORS VE TSH
SES  R IIS
RERS THETI N
METIHE F KHE HIT
AIM EWK,ANRYO ER WADANDRG CREIAA
D HEEPN H T
ROIA TWE.
IND.TH OLLCAAT.
E
AU'ST  SIN MLO MC NES.TIERANME S
ONEEOC R A
O  BM D E NT R
TOAI
NG IMB
TTSTR
RIDAREHETHUTJUTHANEL U U BAN D.E
MERE.Y E
UTRCEEA  OP  T
ONS STE ECFOLL HITRGASYT
REWA HAGHY.PO